Our surrogate is her mom in there to support
her. They asked me if I wanted to go in, but
I'm scared. I think it literally all leads
back to Provo Canyon School because they
were so vicious and sadistic.
Being abused in a doctor's setting has made
me have such post-traumatic stress disorder,
so if I'm in there, I would be on the floor
not being able to breathe.
When you're giving birth, it's so scary as
it is. I don't want the surrogate being
stressed out at all.
I just want her to be happy and healthy so
that Phoenix gets here safely.
Let's wash our hands.
Okay. One second, one second.
Meet your son.
So little.
He's super tiny.
I put a diaper on him because he already
peed. Oh, nice.
I was like, if mommy, if he is on mommy
that's going to be a problem.
What is that?
This is his cord.
Oh, it's going to fall. Nope.
Didn't hurt at all. Oh.
I brought you warm blankets to put on top of
you.
It's okay, baby. Okay
enjoy. The first hour is really important
here. It's called the golden hour.
How do you feel about rainbows and unicorns?
Okay. Okay. Love you so much.
Congratulations, you're a mom!
Your first meal.
I always thought it would be toro sushi but
..
Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
This is my first time holding a newborn baby.
And I can't wait for all the firsts.
His first smile, his first word, his first
step. I think I just had so many dreams of
Phoenix just playing with the animals and
going to Disneyland and going to, like, Taco
Bell together.
He is so beautiful, so perfect.
Like, I feel like my life is finally
complete. I'm so obsessed.
Yeah. Yeah, buddy.
So much. Love you, honey.
I love you. Do you love each other so much
for, like, such a good crew.
You have the best mommy in the world, I'm
telling you. You're lucky, I had the best
dad in the world, so I know to be a good
dad.
Oh, you're so cute.
It's so easy there.
Precious. So happy.
You're going to have the best life with
the best mama and
dada. We're going to have so many adventures.
You're going to be so loved.
Oh. Oh, yeah.
Oh, my beautiful baby.
I love him.
Time to go home.
So precious.
He's like clamping onto my hands.
We're home.
Did you see how to do it?
All right. Just take your time.
It's okay. Okay.
That's good. Oh.
Oh, bright Phoenix.
Ready for your forever home.